greetings of peace assalamualaikum
welcome to the d show and our next guest
went through the bar mitzvah celebrated
Hanukkah Yom Kippur and here's to tell
us about his journey to where he's at
today started with Judaism and he ended
up it's a surprise when we come back
many of you guessed it already those
that haven't sit tight we'll be right
back here on the D show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
assalamualaikum greetings apiece
walaikum assalam wa rahmatullahi wa
barakaatuh - thank you pass Stanford
Pass yes yes we have a yes hum vlog
we're here in New Jersey so you're
you're you were born in New Jersey no
actually I was born in st. Louis
Missouri moved around the country a lot
moved to New Jersey in 1966 when I was a
senior in high school then my life
became like an odyssey a lot of
traveling came back to New Jersey
most recently after the death of my
father may Allah shine on his grave he
he he said he saw the light he saw that
Muhammad was a prophet and he saw that
that the Torah and the gospel both came
from the same one God before he passed
so I came up here to be with my mother
and to help her who also who just passed
away three weeks ago so I came up here
to to be near my family you just gave
away the surprise they fit everybody's
figured it out already there's no
surprises Bar Mitzvah most people have
no idea what does that mean you were bar
mr. English when when a Jewish boy turns
13 he's considered a man I guess because
puberty setting in in the old days and
you're 13 it's about time to get married
and take a plow and go down to the South
40 and go live your life when you're a
young teenager in the old days but now
it's more of a traditional symbolic
gesture where the young man is called up
to the Torah reads a portion and then
he's considered a man in the Jewish
faith you need 10 people to pray so if
he goes to the temple at the prayer time
he's considered he counts after that and
now I also mentioned the Hanukkah
Hanukkah celebrated around the same time
as a stack full of Christmas it is not
the same holiday at all it's so there
was a battle though Maccabee brothers
were fighting a tyrant they were
cornered in a place where there was only
a
oil in a lamp to last a day and Allah
made it last eight days so I'm the law
that's what they celebrate and but
nowadays it's been kind of degenerated
into a materialistic thing with presents
to compete with what else is going on in
the world but it was originally a
holiday to celebrate a victory a
military victory there was a miracle and
also Yom Kippur what is this Kippur
follows Rosh Hashanah Rosh Hashanah is
the new year
then there's ten days of atonement and
then there's one day of fasting Yom
Kippur which is the day of atonement
where the Jews stand most of the day in
the temple they fast from the night
before to the following evening and it's
the only fast in the religion that are
consciously aware of and they're asking
God to forgive them and to be written in
the book of life for the coming year
that was what your computers so we
pretty much know that Jews they end up
believing in the prophets of bateau
Moses they full stop there yes they do a
full stop at Moses and then continue and
then from there they reject Jesus peace
be upon him and yes they say Jesus was a
great teacher at worst I don't even want
to mention it okay and then Mohammed
they also accept but these aren't you
see just like in Islam where I'm only in
five year reverts so I can't quote
chapters and verses but I remember some
of the stories the prophets allah alayhi
wasalam said that there would be 71
misguided there be over 70 misguided
sects in Judaism Christianity and Islam
and the only straight path is the
straight is the straight way Quran and
Sunna without innovation so when I first
became Muslim I said oh great I thought
I was home free I became Muslim this is
it home base and they said no this is
the where you start learning this is you
have a lot to a long way to go Jews they
stopped at Moses yes Christians go ahead
elevate Jesus to God yes but you ended
up accepting Jesus yes and as a Jew you
ended up yes accepting Jesus and
Muhammad and now you're Muslim today yes
I was I was in a Christian monastery and
during my search I was on a hippie farm
I was in these I did some Eastern
meditation in my search for the truth
when I was 14 years old two things
happened most of the hair fell out of me
that's why I don't have a BF I could
grow hair I have a beard that I have to
put in my pocket but Allah gave me a few
whiskers since I became Muslim but I
haven't grown here on my body since I
was about 20 so it's encouraging though
I read that the people in Jenna have no
hair so maybe maybe I don't know a lot
he separated me from the at when it
first happened I thought it was very
terrible I was a teenager teenagers can
be very tough on you but now as you know
when I grew up and and became a man it
became popular to shave your head and
now as a Muslim I it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter been married twice have
two grown sons one is Muslim were the
one who led me to Islam so he accepted
Islam before you yes but the two things
that happened when I was 14 is when I
lost all my hair to President Kennedy
was assassinated and I was watching the
TV and I saw I could tell they were
lying to us about what happened I saw
pictures that didn't coincide with the
with the story so at that point in time
I knew that something was going on that
was fishy and that began my search for
like truth what's really going on in the
world what's really going on in life and
I started looking behind the scenes of
everything that was happening in the
world and found out that there's a
reality going on that we most people
know nothing about and the rest is an
illusion it's been created that we live
in and when it's when I finally got to
the point of when 9/11 happened then it
got to the point where I realized the
illusion even extends to God not that he
could be touched by it but people can be
can be influenced by media by stories
propaganda and so forth so that is very
much of a reason why I was in a position
where Allah allowed me to become Muslim
because my mind was open I wasn't into
peer pressure because of the hair I was
into finding the truth because of
Kennedy's assassination and I wasn't
letting any fences in front of me or
peer pressure or anything
stop me from getting to where I wanted
to be which was I wanted to know why am
I here why am i alive now for a lot of
people they didn't have as as intense or
as you know heavy experiences growing up
so a lot of people who may have had a
very sheltered life may not may look at
me and go well you know that's good for
you
when people say to me I'm glad you
finally found something in your life
that works for you it feels like I'm in
a burning building and I found the fire
escape and I'm telling people around me
there's a fire escape right here and
they're going I'm glad you found
something that works for you I'm telling
you that it's like but you can't all
we're here to do is convey the message
Allah knows best now your story doesn't
stop there you also spent before we go
to break tell us you also spent some
time in a monastery yes when I left the
farm I was hitchhiking around and I was
in Chicago and I I saw a brother a young
man doing some exercise on the beach but
I saw some light around him and I said
who are you from who are you and he said
I'm with this holy order so I went back
to this house with him and where there
was like a monastery and I didn't leave
for three years and I was sent around in
different places around the country and
they were teaching it was called Pauline
Catholic and I don't even know what that
really means I guess there because they
base it on Paul and they were teaching
the Christian mysteries so to speak but
it was in the Trinity was involved in
you
anyway I heard about the Eastern
meditator and then I left the monastery
went to do Eastern meditation got
married during that time for 21 years
had two two sons so I've been searching
for the truth since I was 14 and look at
us now we're gonna be right back with
this incredible story we got to go to
break and we're right back here live in
New Jersey with our special guest here
on the D show don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with brother pass
that's your last name yes and tell us a
little bit more for those people that
don't know you know about Judaism what
were some of the beliefs and why didn't
you stick with those beliefs well the
basic belief of Judaism is the same
basic belief of Christianity in Islam
its monotheism from the time I could
hear and understand English I heard hear
o Israel the Lord our God is one when I
would go on Friday night to the temple
with my family they I'm eternally
grateful to my parents for putting
monotheism into my into my head in my
heart at such an early age in Judaism
there are sets as we all know there in
all the religions ranging from way out
Orthodox to way out reform so you've got
extremes on both ends and then you've
got a lot in the middle I was raised in
what they call conservative judaism
which was kind of judaism american-style
judaism kind of watered-down it didn't
practice all the laws and my mother kept
a kosher home so that's like halal I ate
halal like kosher food all my life she
lit the candles on Friday night there
were celebrations at the dining room
table family was a big deal always a big
deal which is the same as in Islam but I
mean in in
original commandments of the Torah
there's like ten basic Commandments and
then there's like 613 other Commandments
and the priesthood of the Jewish people
during that time the rabbi's were
getting really corrupted and holding
people's feet to the fire about every
little thing and really making a killing
on sacrifices and so forth like the
money changers at the temple that Jesus
turned over when he came peace be upon
him so when Jesus came peace be upon him
I learned he is the last prophet to the
Jews and the Messiah of the Old
Testament he wasn't the world prophet he
was the last one who came for the Jews
and that's even explained in some places
in the New Testament a Canaanite woman
comes to him and says would you heal my
daughter he said I just came for the
Lost Tribe of Israel I didn't come for
you and then she humbles herself and
says it's something and he heals her
daughter by the power of Allah and so to
me Jesus peace be upon him did not come
to start a religion to me in reality
there is no such thing as Christianity
it's an illusion people created if Jesus
did not create Christianity peace be
upon him and it was created after him it
was a brand some money maker there were
sincere people involved but the ones who
really juiced it and turned it into a
big business what can I say may Allah
guide them but in order to be Muslim
it's like I didn't renounce Moses or
renounce Jesus I just backed up and read
the last chapter of the three-volume set
and I accept them all I accept a ball
and that doesn't mean I followed the 613
commandments of the Old Testament when a
new covenant is made the Old Covenant is
not is not necessary anymore what I
follow now is the Quran and the Sunnah
which is the updated Sharia the Ten
Commandments were Sharia the golden the
new gospel was Sharia yes Sharia just
means what passageway to water the God's
law it's God's law so the God's lon
was in the corral when people get
attached to the prophets or get attached
to the book or get attached to the
religion just like waving the flag at
summer camp my cabin can be your cabin
it's not about that it's about following
God not following a prophet not
following a religion but following where
God's leading and God led us he led me
from my from my Jewish roots which were
being born Muslim of course at first
with the fitrah and all but then being
raised Jewish and then going through
everything I went through was like a
loss like sped up my my just took me
around the block a lot took me around
the block and drop me off where I belong
because I love God I've always loved God
I love the truth I've always loved the
truth and so Allah said meet your family
meet the people that are following me
that are in real time that are in real
time this is real time in in video
you've got real time you're not tape not
you know if this was live it's not live
but real time is now right now this is
the Ummah of God it's over Muhammad but
it's the people that believers in the
one God doing it the way he said to do
it yeah so so tell us now we know that
we as Muslims we truly want the best for
all of mankind doesn't matter if you're
a Jew watching this a Christian
whoever's out there we know that the
last the final messenger peace be upon
him we see from his tradition even when
there was a Jewish funeral and the
Prophet peace be upon him he stood up
and his companion said this is a Jewish
man he said is that not a soul right
right so definitely now we also see
through history and can you explain to
us is different coming from someone of
who was formerly from the Jewish
background we see at the time because a
lot of this conflict this is something
new now but way back in the day didn't
Muslims when Jews were being persecuted
and we have famous rabbi who's out there
today's an Orthodox rabbi rabbi Weiss
and he talks about this and a lot of the
Orthodox rabbis they talk about how you
know the
babysit the Jewish people's kids they
fled persecution you know the Jews and
Muslims protected them can you talk
about this
I have a picture on my facebook wall of
an old Jewish man with the black hat and
the black coat no beard walking arm in
hand in hand holding hands with an Arab
Palestinian Arab wearing the I don't
know the the cloth on the head with the
ring around it and so yeah this is what
was circa in 1923
all right here's what happened World War
one was going on there were a group of
German Jews who were Zionists who had
emigrated from a place called Caesarea
which is Eastern Europe there was a mass
conversion of who whatever they were
before to Jews there are cannot see Jews
Eastern European Jews all right
among those Jews there were some there
was a small group of them that were like
had to control everything small group of
them and they still exist and they are
controlling Allah is allowing it and
these people went to England and said to
England we can help you win World War
one they were in World War one they said
we can help you win World War one we can
get the United States involved so
England says yeah what do you want the
and the Zionists said we want Palestine
okay not as a homeland that the the the
storyline is as a homeland for the Jews
what's really going on is something else
which I won't go into right now but so
it was called the Balfour Declaration
1917 where England gave Palestine to the
Zionists but it wasn't theirs it's like
if I gave him this jacket this is your
jacket I can't give especially you know
I can't do that I can't take your jacket
but is but
listen I didn't have guns you see pal
his britain had a lot more guns than
Palestine
so Burton says sure we'll give you a
Palestine which wasn't theirs to give
and that was the beginning and then all
the people that I grew up thinking we're
heroes who built Israel were really had
really like decimated the Palestinian
people and just as a footnote my parents
are good and decent people they were in
the dark they didn't know a lot of
Americans used have no idea what's
really going on so since the Balfour
Declaration this whole thing about
babysitting the kids while the other
ones would go to pray and be an extra
neighbors Jews and Arabs and Muslims and
Jews that went away and all of a sudden
you've got you've got a political agenda
which has nothing to do with the
religion try ID theft Inger we lit the
place called Israel and saying this is
the Jewish homeland when in truth
semitism Semite is someone from
Southwest Asia most of the people in
Israel are from Eastern Europe they're
not from Southwest Asia if they want a
homeland they could go to Southwest Asia
the Semites are the Palestinians they're
from that area they're from Southwest
Asia which is that what they call the
Middle East yeah so there's been a
tremendous baton baton switch kind of
thing happen and it's been political and
it's got bigger it's got bigger
ramifications as we approach the hour
now when we come back we want to also
find out what actually at the end now
you went from Judaism father mother
Jewish we talked about the Hanukkah Bar
Mitzvah you did all that and now you're
actually a Muslim one who submits to the
crater alone not the creation you
believe in Jesus Moses and alas the
final measure problem ahamed you're a
Muslim yes love we're gonna be right
back with more to hear this incredible
story here on the D show don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
back here on the D show with this
incredible story of brother pass father
mother your father actually your son
first accepted Islam yes and your father
also accepted Islam yes he did not have
time in his life to openly practice it
he was he was dying but he declared his
understanding and his aunt and his
belief that that there is only one God
which he believed all his life and that
Muhammad truly was a Prophet SAW Allah
with a wasalam and that the Torah and
the Quran both came from the same God
you have I mean instances where many
Jewish scholars one in particular during
the last and final message of our
Muhammad's time he was one of the chief
rabbis at that time he also was someone
who was familiar you know about the
story yes yes so that reminds us now
that you know any sincere person rather
he be a Jew or Christian anybody I mean
who's looking for the truth as this
particular person when he saw the signs
of Prophet Muhammad he came investigated
and he was the chief rabbi at that time
and he accepted that Muhammad peace be
upon was the last final messenger but
now for those Jews that are out there
according because they're waiting for
the Messiah right which we believe Jesus
peace be upon him is the Messiah but now
according to the Christian description
of course they were going to reject him
because now they look at him as a
literal son of God as a God but do you
feel now if the Jews would really look
into Islam to see the description that
we have of Jesus that they were actually
accept him and then move on to Muhammad
peace be upon him you get the point
as I do and from my experience with Dawa
what I have to say is this you can have
every fact you can have every piece of
information just right you can present
it like a champ you can present it that
would put a smile on the prophet's face
allah alayhi wasalam god
guidance is in the hands of a law but
let's say there is that those few
sincere people that's described now what
was the
description of what the the Christians
are describing so now someone if he's
sincerely looking at that he's gonna
reject that as its I but the Islamic
view right of what Jesus is right right
that's a seer person if he's a Jew and
he's out there and he's like this guy's
Jewish I'm having some trouble here you
know what I mean yes and I it looks like
you know something's pointing him in the
Islamic direction right he wants to move
on right so maybe attached to his
preconceived notions and if he looks
with an objective eye and an open heart
he'll see it unless Allah for some
reason has something over his eyes
because of something that we don't know
is in his heart but if his heart is his
pure if his takia is clean and and his
heart is sound and his mind is objective
he will see it yeah but unfortunately
that's not common may Allah help this to
become more common my and I again I
don't know the chapters and verses but
my understanding is that when Jesus
returns peace be upon him that did a lot
of Jews will accept him and will
understand who he is I guess you know
something like that happens what are you
gonna do you say I still don't believe
some me I don't know but from what I
understand they're gonna have an
opportunity and I I want to be part of
that when I became Muslim before I
became Muslim I was a caricature artist
I used to draw people's faces I used to
make a lot of good money doing that at
parties and things like that when I
became Muslim they said you can't do
that anymore you can't draw faces I said
well what I was making good money when
you give up something for the sake of
Allah who give you something better
so I moved from the little town in
Arkansas where I lived up in the hills
and I moved to Jonesboro which was the
nearest community of Muslims and Islamic
Center of Jonesboro say hey mom Rock
Manohar V out there in Jonesboro I was
Arkansas State University was there and
I that's where I found out I could go
back to college for free because they
it's called the silver Scholar Program
and they give free tuition to people
over 60 so I said hamdullah like and
finish college and show this degree to
my father whose heart I broke when I
dropped out of college 45 years ago he
was lying on his deathbed and I showed
him the degree and if the look on his
face was priceless and then he told my
son and me that he understood what we
were saying so there was a tremendous
amount of love and letting go and
opening there so did I answer your yes
yes absolutely we're almost out of time
so now that you're a Muslim is it so far
off now for someone who would have to
he's a someone of the Jewish background
and now the person is sincere what would
they have to do what are the things that
you had to do now to end up becoming a
Muslim so we've talked about in the
beginning ok the Jews they stopped at
Moses right but you cannot reject if God
sent Jesus which he did not as a God or
literal son of God you cannot reject
Jesus and now say you're paying God
because if God sent a messenger so you'd
have to accept Jesus and Muhammad as the
last let's talk about this the
importance of this yeah there are so
many versions of the New Testament out
there it's it's a challenge and there
are so many sets of Jews and Christians
and it's a challenge to try to sync up
with someone because there are some
Christians who don't worship Jesus and
there are most of them do there are some
Christians who don't believe in the
Trinity and there are some Christians
that do so one of the basic points when
I'm having Donald with a Christian is
number one they start cracking on the
women wearing things on their head I
said did you ever see a picture of Mary
peace be upon her or may Allah be
pleased with anything with her head
uncovered did you ever see a picture or
a statue of of Maryam may Allah be
pleased with their head uncovered no
what's this with you be having multiple
wives I said Abraham had multiple
Solomon had multiple wives Islam didn't
invent multiple wives you know every
time you know it comes on what about
stoning the people for adultery I'm the
one you know this was meant to be a
strong determined if you look at the
parameters for that it's not next to
it'sit's like very unlikely you're gonna
get four witnesses and all this other
it's a strong deterrent it's not meant
to be a weekly event after Juma you know
so but a lot of the people in the world
they have concepts because they believe
the media just like people believe what
the doctors tell them instead of going
to nature are going to natural remedies
they'll go to pharmaceuticals instead of
going to the source
I tell people they need the authentic
beneficial knowledge you know it's just
like saying there's two thousand
architects and engineers on the internet
there's all say 9/11 was a controlled
demolition
more than 1300 architects and engineers
examine the evidence about building
sevens collapse and disagree with the
official report issued by the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
I certainly am much more open-minded
about it than I was and it is because of
the involvement of the 9/11 families and
all these engineers and architects you
are about to hear from architect of 23
years Richard gage AIA member the
American Institute of Architects and
founder of Architects and engineers for
9/11 truth now there are more than 1500
architects and engineers who say that it
could not have been brought down by
office fires they are backed by 9/11
family members who are calling for an
independent unbiased investigation I'm a
family member trying to find out the
answers to the murder of three
thousand-plus people
the bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated properly
please architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this then there's some deep deep
explaining to do
it took some kind of
consciousness-raising on my part before
I was willing to look at the
possibilities and really you need to go
for the evidence leads as an engineer I
have three degrees in engineering I
signed that petition for architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth some time ago
because the American people absolutely
need the truth of 9/11 look at the
evidence in fact I'll say this very
categorically any reasonable person who
looks at the evidence that's been
brought forward has got to come away
with the feeling that something has to
be done in a real investigation has to
be put forward
we will never heal this country will
never ever ever forget that day we have
to demand a new investigation I want
justice here
and there's still people those doggone
Muslims did it you know it's just like
some people just won't and so so all I'm
trying to do is hone my skills to be the
best conveyor of the message that I can
be that's all I can do and make dua for
them that's powerful I learned I heard
something recently and says do I can
change destiny to think of that it's
like I want to make more dua for because
there's so many people I want to help
but you can't help them on this plane
but you can make dua for them and it can
it can it's very powerful because you
got a love and working on your side for
that person - before we go also you
mentioned some of the misconceptions and
you know people that they quote things
out of context what about now with all
the hype with all of the you know
attacks on Islam and people are showing
a fringe element a group of extremists
and their aperture what would you get
hit with this a lot sure
sure I do and I tell people that Isis is
- Islam what meat glue is - filet mignon
okay it's all it's not now somebody
explain what what big blue is for people
that have no idea who is that stuff they
create nowadays it's kind of like the
pink slime they make McNuggets on them
only it's red meat instead of pink slime
it's they take scraps from the machines
on the floor and they that he's they use
some kind of a chemical adhesive that's
digestible and they shape it into a
steak and shape it into things you got
to really keep an eye on things and
that's why it's such a blessing Allah
knew a lot knew what the food supply was
gonna happen and he may allow for us for
and he knew so I tell people to do some
research I told people to do some
homework and don't believe everything
they read they see in the media don't
believe anything they see in the media
without doing some research that's what
I tell people to do and depending on
where they're at I say different things
to different people
now you also had a
you have that special message you wanted
to share with the world that we had
talked about I wanted to express
gratitude to my family to my parents for
putting me on the path of monotheism
when I was a little boy and I'm
eternally grateful for that and they did
the best they could with what they had
what do you have last closing comments
and suggestions for the people who are
searching for what you were searching
for you you went all around basically
you know the world almost you know
searching for the truth and you found it
for the individuals that are out there
who are searching and now they're kind
of in stuck but they've tuned on to the
D so what advice would you have okay
lose your hair be a hippie oh no no it's
different for everybody pray to God to
help you to guide you that's what it's
about the name of this channel is so
appropriate because we asked a lot of
guidance how many times a day this is
the most powerful thing we can do is we
can ask Allah to help us we make duaa to
be kept under straight it's all in the
first chapter it's all in alpha to you
it's all there
it's all there I couldn't make I
couldn't say it any better of course not
thank you very much for being with us
thank you she's not gonna care may Allah
reward you greatly for this and thank
you for having me
and thank you for tuning on to the D
show and everybody is with us here in
New Jersey continue to tune on and
anybody that's out there that searching
for the truth ask the one who created
you who created the hearts to guide your
heart it doesn't matter if you're from a
Jewish background Christian Hindu it
doesn't mean that you now have the
opportunity if you're searching
sincerely for the purpose of life why
you've been creating why you're here ask
the one who created you and he will
definitely make the way clear and we'll
see you next time here on the details
same time same channel subscribe now if
you haven't already follow us Facebook
Twitter we'll see you next time peace be
with you please subscribe to the video
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]